so what should you use if you need a
complex data storage system well there's
one more system the indexed database API
also called index DB for short index
database was designed in response to web
sequel and its sequel light variant
index database is not a sequel API it's
a simpler index storage system on which
you could build an optimized query
implementation likes a sequel variant
this means it isn't optimized to a
particular query system instead when you
create your database you define what
indexes you want to use if you've never
done database storage before index DB
may take a little bit of getting used to
but it's actually pretty straightforward
the spec itself has some really good
examples in it this code is based on the
spec first you need to open your
database and you need to be prepared to
initialize the database if it hasn't
been opened before when you initialize
the database you can define the indexes
in the database that is what attributes
are easily searchable you can change
this later to you just have to upgrade
the database and of course you can
inspect the databases in the developer
tools to see what's going into the index
DB store and check to make sure it's
organized the way you want it just go
into the resources tab select index DB
and there you go you can see your
objects right there if you expand them
you can even see the values